je suis architecte en intelligence
artificielle intelligence artificielle
waouh ça y est c'est dash est un grand
terme un grand mot qui en définitive
veut pas dire grand chose comme je dis
souvent aux etats unis c'est un peu
bullshit même l'intelligence
artificielle juste un terme que l'on
utilise pour recouvrir toute une série
de disciplines
l'intelligence artificielle est déjà
présente aujourd'hui dans votre
quotidien vous l'utilisez tous les jours
sans vous en rendre compte
mais là différentes étapes dans son
cycle de vie et elle est intimement liée
à la vie de l'humanité et peut-être plus
encore de l'univers c'est ce que nous
allons essayer de comprendre aujourd'hui
où je vais tenter de vous expliquer
comment au bout de ses 16 années de
réflexion de recherche et de création
d'outils en intelligence artificielle
j'en suis peut-être arriver à une forme
de cette conclusion mais d'abord vous
expliquer mon parcours à l'âge de 8 ans
petit accident je me retrouve quelques
jours dans un coma avec un réveil qui se
passe de manière assez étrange très
rapide debout sur mes pieds je suis
parti et la volonté de découvrir tout ce
qui existe tout ce qui existe dans notre
monde de notre univers quelles sont ses
origines qu'elle est l'univers en
définitive à ce que l'univers est finie
est-ce qu'il est infinie est ce qu'il
est bordé ce qui est abordé est-ce qu'il
ya plusieurs univers quel est le sens de
tout ça parce qu'il s'étend dans le
temps dans l'espace et en définitive
quel est le sens de la vie qui se trouve
avec tous ces éléments là et je me pose
la question je pose forcément la
question à mes proches imaginez souvenez
vous la photo où j'étais présent plus ou
moins dans cet âge là ça pouvait
intrigué pas mal de personnes
et je cherche je pose des questions et
non content d'avoir des réponses auprès
des adultes qui sont autour de moi je
commence à chercher dans les bouquins à
lire et à me rendre compte d'une chose
de de découvrir qu'en définitive l'homme
a une date de péremption
mais pourtant l'homme a besoin de
transmettre son information sa
connaissance les sens de ce qu'il est
pour se donner un sens et l'homme pour
cela perspicace trouve toujours des
solutions
il créa le livre le livre pour résoudre
en définitive cette limite du temps mais
il créa en même temps la plus grande
organisation carcéral de la connaissance
les bibliothèques regardez ce livre qui
est dans mes mains ce livre imaginaire
noir avec une magnifique couverture qui
traitent justement de l'information il
est une prison pour moi ce livre est
fermé et je lui rends visite rarement
beaucoup trop rarement preuve est gelée
même oublié à l'arrière je l'ouvrais je
le consulte je consomme son information
sa connaissance et je leur ferme pour le
laisser là où il était présent
voilà la limite du temps et la création
du livre propre à l'être humain qui
s'est rendu compte que ses limites et
est la transmission à ses pairs ses amis
et ses paires par an directement et il
créa le livre pour résoudre ceux ci mais
justement comment se passe toute cette
collecte d'informations je vous invite à
aller visiter ce site sur une formation
et beautiful qui explique énormément de
choses sur justement l'information
comment fonctionne le processus de
collecte de l'information et ce depuis
le premier jour il ya des dates à des
mesures des faits des actions énormément
d'éléments qui sont collectés dans la
vie quotidienne pour être transformée
pour être torréfié pour être informé et
j'aime bien utiliser le terme
informations en deux mots pour montrer
que c'est de la formation pour créer de
la connaissance et peut-être à terme on
l'espère de la sagesse mais tous a
démarré il ya déjà très
longtemps bien avant le livre et j'ai
découvert ça avec un de mes coaches par
le passé qui lui est en docteur en
psychologie en descriptions en fait et
décryptage des dessins d'enfants ayant
travaillé sur les grottes de lascaux
donc le docteur michel schiro a
découvert en définitive des tableaux
magnifiques dont celui ci trois chevaux
qui évolue de la matérialité à
l'immatérialité à la dématérialisation
il me présente ça comme étant regard du
participe au schéma qui se trouvaient
déjà inscrits dans les grottes de
lascaux et les grottes de lascaux était
juste un premier support on a évolué
ensuite dans les livres et non content
des livres qui pouvait se passer de
personne en personne
il fallait aller plus vite plus loin et
gutenberg est arrivé gutenberg à créer
l'impression la capacité de distribuer
de dupliquer les livres de le donner aux
proches mais ont rencontré une nouvelle
limite propre à l'humanité c'est à dire
que si j'ai ce bouquin qui est reproduit
je peux vous donne à vous mais comment
je fais pour l'étendre plus loin pour
distribuer cette information cette
connaissance que j'ai si durement
collecter transformer torréfié pour la
mettre à disposition dans ce bouquin on
découvre une seconde limite qui va être
l'espace cette limite des spas cette
capacité de pouvoir communiquer peu
importe où où que nous soyons va être
dépassé encore une fois par l'homme qui
est juste extraordinaire au travers
d'une nouvelle technologie de
l'invention de l'internet
avant ça de l'ordinateur merci turing
merci tim berners lee sort tim berners
lee qui ont été en définitive nous
prédécesseur donc gutenberg alan turing
dont on parle pas mal pour l'instant et
tim berners lee et cet espace va pouvoir
en fait se dupliquer se déployer au
travers d'internet que vous connaissiez
excessivement bien et là on rentre dans
un phénomène que vous connaissez que
vous
vivez au quotidien kg et plus de donner
plus de dettes à plus d'informations
autant verticale qu'à l'horizontale à un
point de se retrouver en fait submerger
par cette information par toute cette
donnée et le besoin de mieux le
comprendre puisque quoiqu'il en soit
l'homme est impatient tout comme
l'enfant comme mes enfants j'ai trois
enfants lorsqu'ils viennent me voir ils
me posent des questions ils ne veulent
pas que je leur dise ne bouge pas tu vas
aller dans cette bibliothèque l'a
peut-être trouvé un bouquin un magazine
et éventuellement dans mes notes
tu trouveras la réponse à comment on
fait les enfants papa pourtant c'est
bien ça c'est bien le monde dans lequel
nous vivons aujourd'hui
nous avions le livre la bibliothèque et
la bibliothécaire
cette super intendance en fait de la
connaissance et nous reproduisons juste
dans le plus le même schéma nous avons
internet constitué de blogs constitué de
communautés constituées de sites
internet de pages web et nous avons des
moteurs de recherche qui sont là pour
nous montrer où se trouvent les
informations ce super intendant se
garant de la connaissance qui dans
certains cas peut engendrer un effet big
brother et l'homme reçoit trop il reçoit
beaucoup d'informations beaucoup de
données il n'arrive plus à traiter de
par ses éléments preuve est aujourd'hui
combien d'entre vous utilisent plutôt
les réseaux sociaux pour filtrer la
connaissance est allé voir les liens
relayée par les amis que plutôt des
recherches et lui même nous sommes juste
un effet permanent de distribution de
cette information la connaissance
puisqu'en définitive
ce qu'il faut c'est mettre sa
disposition du plus grand nombre puisque
élevé une civilisation une société celle
ci ne s'élève pas par l'élite
elle s'élève par le peuple le fait de
distribuer cette information cette
connaissance au plus grand nombre et
c'est pour ça que je travaille dans
l'intelligence
elle pour la distribuer au plus grand
nombre la rendre disponible pour tout à
chacun
et ce wave qui est là qui engendre
aujourd'hui un point de rupture dans le
volume de données dans cette incapacité
par l'homme de pouvoir la traiter en
tant que telle non seulement par l'om
mais par les objets connectés la
robotique tous ces éléments qui lui
amène des flots d'informations
conséquent l'homme a besoin d' aide et
encore une fois l'homme et fasse au plus
et il va tenter de chercher mieux mieux
accéder à l'information comme je vous
disais à quelques instants mon enfant
qui aime poser la question il ne
recherche pas un bouquin ils recherchent
une réponse directe une information de
ma part qui a été traité par ma part et
de la même manière l'homme l'être humain
est tout aussi impatients que l'enfant
et souhaite avoir la réponse directement
je souhaite plus recherchés dans un
moteur de recherche pour avoir des liens
de manière infinie je veux avoir la
réponse à ma question directement traité
près analyser et c'est en ça que en
définitive
l'intelligence artificielle que vous
connaissez déjà aujourd'hui par pleins
d'applications et nous mêmes nous avions
lancé avec notre équipe une application
il ya quelques années en france qui
avait été un vrai succès on parle de
syrie on parle de google là où on parle
de watson nous avions lancé angie en son
temps tous ces éléments vont être là en
définitive pour accompagner l'homme dans
le traitement de cette information est
potentiellement libérer cette
information pour la rendre plus fluide
et la distribuer au plus grand nombre au
travers de ses diverses qui sont tous
dans vos poches
mais pas que nous travaillons
aujourd'hui sur l'intégration dans le
monde de l'automobile
ça peut non seulement distribuer
l'information mais également sauver des
vies
combien d'entre vous n'ont pas eu une
frayeur en tentant de répondre à un
texto en regardant son téléphone en
roulant l'homme elia peuvent être
combinées pour résoudre ce genre de
problématique en conduite ne pas vous
punir vous dire que vous ne pouvez pas
utiliser l'une aimant
bien vous donner des outils pour
continuer d' usage que vous recherchez
imaginez un autre cas avec un médecin de
manière intuitive le médecin va poser un
diagnostic mais il n'a pas la
connaissance et l'histoire de tous les
cas comme vous préalablement lien pourra
l'accompagner dans ses décisions pour
lui donner un regarde j'ai fait une
prennent à l'iss pour toi je te ramène
toutes les informations tu peux poser un
diagnostic beaucoup plus juste
maintenant l'idée est vraiment de passer
de cette civilisation du plus qui est
celle dans laquelle nous sommes encore
aujourd'hui mais en transition vers une
civilisation du mieux et du mieux non
pas pour nous du mieux pour nos enfants
et en conclusion tout comme la pomme est
un outil au service de la transmission
de l'essence du pommier l'homme en
créant l'intelligence artificielle est
en définitive un outil de libération de
la connaissance et de continuité de la
société de notre civilisation
ainsi tout comme gutenberg
nous devons poursuivre cet effort de
collecter l'information de la pousser
vers des intelligences artificielles
pour les remettre à notre disposition au
travers de tous ces éléments et apporter
cette fameuse graines de changement
merci